that's just kind of what each of us want
to do and kind of makes things that
people hopefully enjoy but also can
benefit their lives michael jackson's
youngest child blanket bg jackson is all
grown up and giving a rare interview
about how he and his siblings 23 year
old paris and 24 year old prince
continued to honor their father's legacy
12 years after his death my brother has
a really unique talent on monday the 19
year old spoke to good morning britain
walking around a room filled with his
dad's belongings
there's a lot of really cool stuff here
i think
there's a lot of history in this house
and the studio here that's what he was
all about and that's just kind of what
each of us want to do and kind of makes
things that people hopefully enjoy but
also can benefit their lives
fiji also revealed his passion
advocating for climate change i do think
it's important that we all know about it
and
i think we have some work to do but our
generation knows how important it is the
teen's interview comes just days after
his big brother spoke to the same
british morning show and opened up about
his relationship with his siblings when
we were growing up my father would say
we could have nothing but you look
around in this room your brother your
sister and me that's all you'll ever
have and that always stuck with my
siblings and i and we have such a close
relationship and because i'm the oldest
you know my father would always tell me
i have to make sure that the group
is taken care of and that i have to kind
of be the leader and lead by example but
after his passing and kind of us being
thrown into the quote unquote real world
my siblings honestly they picked up the
slack that i unfortunately left behind
now that they're all grown up prince
said he doesn't really feel like there's
a hierarchy anymore my sister has her
strengths and my brother has his
strengths and where i'm not as strong in
certain areas they complement me in that
way any moment that i get to spend with
my siblings now especially as we're
getting older you know and our own lives
are starting to kind of blossom and grow
every moment that i get with them any
little family dinner any family outing
is is really a special moment for me
when eti spoke to prince back in 2019 at
his annual halloween party to benefit
his charity kiel los angeles foundation
shortly after he graduated from loyola
marymount university he opened up about
his next chapter i feel like the world
is my oyster now i have so many
different opportunities i feel that my
time is best devoted to the non-profit
right now because that's where my
passion lies and that's where i feel i
will get the most out of my life i still
have a creative bug and i'm figuring out
how i'm fitting into the
entertainment industry i really have a
few projects that i'm really working on
but i want to make sure they're
solidified before i talk about them but
i'm definitely excited to see what the
future holds for me it's somewhere in
the entertainment with the philanthropic
side of it for sure though i think as
for paris et spoke to the singer back in
september and she said she's the
happiest she's ever been i'm good i'm
the happiest i've ever been which is
really nice to say and i just feel good
i feel healthy it's good to be present
especially for things that mean like so
much to me what is it what is making you
so happy probably the music spending
time with good people and
my spiritual life is
pretty great
you